hello everyone
welcome to this video tutorial by simply
learn in this video
we will learn about overfitting and
under fitting in machine learning
we have our experience instructor
richard who will take us through this
video and help us understand the basics
of overfitting and under fitting
the reasons why it occurs and finally we
look at a demo in python
over to richard now what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
science is overfitting and under fitting
what does that mean
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with
the noise and the data tries to fit each
data point
on the curve you can see that
um if you plug in your coordinates
you're just going to get the
whatever it's fitted every point on the
data stream there's no average there's
no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because
if the wind blows a certain way um in
the efficiency of your car maybe you
have a headwind
so your car might alter how efficient it
is as it goes and so there's going to be
this variance on here
and this says no you can't have any
variance with you know the this is it's
going to be exactly this it can't be any
you can't be the same speed or the same
car and have a slightly different
efficiency so
as the model has very less flexibility
it fails to predict
new data points and thus the model
rejects every new data point during the
prediction
so you'll get like a really high error
on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting data
used for training is not cleaned and
contains
noise garbage values in it you can spend
so much time
cleaning your data and it's so important
it's so important that if you have if
you have some kind of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data
maybe they use in medical different
measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b
or even off of machine a and machine b
is testing something
and those those numbers are coming in
wrong
the model has a high variance again wind
is a good example
i was talking about that with the car
you may have 100 tests but because the
wind's blowing it's all over the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small amount of data
is going to also cause this problem you
only have a few points and you try to
plot everything
the model is too complex this comes up a
lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked
and so you have to go back back break it
up and find out actually what correlates
and what doesn't
so what is underfitting a scenario
where machine learning models can either
learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point and you can
see here we have
our efficiency of our car and our line
drawn and it's just going to be way off
for both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns
it accepts every new data point during
the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage and values
again under fitting and overfitting same
issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias we've seen
this
in all kinds of things from
[Music]
the mod the most common is the driving
cars to facial identification
or whatever it is the model itself when
they build it
might have a bias towards one thing and
this would be an underfitted
model would have that bias because it's
averaged it out so if you have
five people from india and 10 people
from
africa and 20 people from the u.s
you created a bias because it's looking
at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about so we have a model with a
high bias we have size of training data
used is not enough
the model is too simple again this is
one straight line through all the data
when it needs a slight shift to it for
other reasons
so what is a good fit a linear curve
that best fits the data is neither
overfitting or
underfitting models but is just right
and of course we have the nice examples
here where we have overfitting
lines going up and down every point is
trying to be include
gluted underfitting the line really is
off from where the data is and then a
good fit is
got to get rid of that minimize that
error coming through
so this is all exciting but what does
this look like so we really need to jump
in and put a code together
and see what this looks like when we're
programming
for this demo we'll bring up our trusty
anaconda
and go into jupiter notebook for python
move myself out of the way here uh and
so
we're going to start off this is going
to be a demo on overfitting and
underfitting using python
and let's start with our imports
now if you've been through enough of
these tutorials we don't want to spend a
huge amount of time on what we're
bringing in and what we're doing
so you should be up on doing this with
python and how to bring in your
different modules
we're going to bring in the sklearn or
the scikit
processing sk learn dot neural network
import in a mlp regressor
so there's our regressor model right
there that's going to be our linear
regression model
and we have our metrics mean absolute
error if you remember we had our
that's how we figure out how well it
fits is how far off that error is based
on the
mean square error value mse
and then of course numpy because we just
like to work with numpy it's a great
data array
we always import it as mp that's the
most common way of doing it
and then we have sklearn model selection
import validation curve so we're going
to look at a validation curve to see how
good our models are
and then we have the data set we'll use
the
very famous iris data set and that's
embedded in
the scikit so the s key learn data sets
have a load iris in there
and then we have the matplot library
because if you're doing any kind of demo
or showing this off to your shareholders
we want to have something nice to
display it on
and then we have sklearn model selection
we're going to import
import k-fold and we'll talk about that
when we get to it
and then we're going to go ahead and do
just for our numpy we're going to do
like a random seed for random numbers
and then for our plot style we'll use
the gg plot
that's just some back end setup you
could even probably leave the plot
style out depending on what version of
you're using of depending on what
version you're using a matplot library
and then we'll go ahead and run this
it's not going to do anything that we
can visibly see because it's just
loading those modules
and then we also want to load our iris
data in here
and the iris data has an iris data and
iris target
we're going to load that as x and y
and just so you can have an idea what
we're talking about we're going to go
ahead and print
x and just the first bit of x we'll just
do the top of x
and we'll also print y so you can see
what the top of y looks like
print y
and since we're a numpy we're going to
go ahead and do our own thing if this
was
of course pandas we could just do the
head of it and see what it looks like
and you can see here we've loaded this
up and in x we have these different
measurements
that they take of the flower the iris
flowers from this particular
data set and what kind of flower it is
it's going to be a zero
one or a two is actually what the target
comes out of even though that doesn't
show in here
and so we're going to come in here and
we're going to use the k folds cross
validation with 20 folds
and a good catch that this was a model
selection
we're we're going through and we're
selecting different parts of the data in
here
here we use k-fold cross validation with
20 folds k equals 20 to evaluate the
generalization efficiency
of the model within each fold we will
then estimate
the training and test error using the
training and test
sets respectfully
so here we have our kf equals kf uh
k fold here's our splits on the top
and then we need to go ahead and have
our list training error we're going to
create an array for that we're going to
list our testing error
and for train index and test index in k
f dot split x x train y uh
x train and x test we're going to go
ahead and split up our
our data our x values and the same thing
with the y values so now we have an x
train and x test a y train and a y test
and then here's our model our impel mlp
regressor
that's your linear regression model in
there and we have used a multi-layer
perceptron
mlp so this is a neural network
multi-layer perceptron that's what the
mlp is for
regressor means that it is dealing with
numbers we're not categorizing things
um and then let's go ahead uh
i kind of went off the screen here we'll
just go ahead and bring that down
it's a class of feed forward artificial
neural networks
and they kind of loosely call it a n
don't get caught up in the a
n n n m n n there's
n n is neural network and then everybody
puts their own flavor on it depending on
what they're doing
uh so if you see the nn you know you're
dealing with a neural network
so we go ahead and fit our data here's
our model.fit
we have x train and y train and the y
train data we're going to predict equals
model.predict
x train so here's our prediction of what
it's going to be
so we've trained it and we predicted it
we've trained our the train data
and then we have our y train and then we
have our y test
and the y test equals a model predict x
test
now notice what we did here is we're
going to use our model to predict
what we think y should be but this is
the training set
uh so we've trained it with this data
and now we want to see how good
our model fits our training data and
then we want to see how well it fits
our testing data so we take our fold
training error mean absolute error y
train
y train data predict and we're gonna do
our full testing error the mean absolute
error of
y test and y test data predict
and we do this and here's our mean
absolute error there's our
a little bit different connotation but
that's that's taking the square value
and finding the in this case it's using
the absolute value so instead of the
square value we get rid of the minus and
pluses by using an absolute value
and we find the average of that and that
works the same way as doing the squared
value
and then we take our list training error
and we're going to just append it
for each each one of these runs we go
through so every time we fold
the data think of it like this
we want to go ahead and take a piece of
data that's going to be
one piece of the data and we're going to
look at
each section and we want to go through
each section to see how well it does and
splits it up
this way we have a nice picture when
we're looking at it from a distance
i do this a lot when i do x and when i
split my x train and my y train
i'll take two thirds of the data and
then one third of the data
and then i'll switch it and i'll do
three different models
so i can really see how well it tests
out and how that averages out
this is the same thing but with the with
the k fold we're doing
and we're doing it across 20 sections
we'll go ahead and run this and we run
this it's not too exciting because we're
just loading up the data and appending
it into our list
and so we want to take with this uh is
we're going to go ahead and plot it
and this is where we can really see
what's going on this is where it gets
exciting
so we take it we're going to create a
couple subplots
that way we have a nice setup down here
we're splitting it up into a couple
different graphs
and let's go ahead and run this and then
we'll walk through it a little bit so
our subplot
comes in
there's our subplot and then our plt
plot we're going to do in there range
one
we're going ahead and do the splits plus
one in p array list training error
uh ravel this is of course just a code
to how we
properly set it up on there so that it
sees it correctly
and then we have our x label which is
our number fold uh plot the y label
training error
plot the title training here across
folds
plot the tight layout plot the subplot
so we're going to move on to
this is one two one one two two there's
our one and just one
and two has to do with how it how it
layers it on there for doing multiple
plots because you can do all kinds of
cool things with our plot
our pi plot library
and again we're going to go ahead and do
the same thing for the error
and we end up with our training error
across folds and our testing area across
folds and so you can see these different
folds how they kind of spike and how
they look
and so we're talking about overfitting
or under fitting
we're comparing these two graphs
and if one of them is more off than the
other one
if you're looking at these two graphs
you guys say hey is this one
overfit or underfit and this is always a
good question to ask
i mean what do we got going here is that
over fit or is that underfit
and i would say based on these two
graphs and the
training data uh the training data is
more sporadic than the testing data
so i would look at this and say hey this
might need to be fit a little bit better
maybe we don't have enough data with the
iris we probably don't
something else is going on here so it's
a little underfit maybe a different
model would fit better
i would not use a neural network model
for this i would actually use just a
basic linear
linear model on this a lot of different
choices
but this gives you an idea what we're
looking at is how chaotic
are these two is it getting better or is
it getting worse
if at some point the training data gets
so much better than the testing data
you know you've over fit it and that's
where you start running into the
overfitting
this to me looks like it's under fit so
that concludes
under fitting and overfitting thank you
for watching this video
i hope it was useful and informative if
you liked this video then please go
ahead and subscribe to simply learn
channel to stay updated with all the
latest trending technologies
stay tuned for more from simply loan
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here